et là c'est du célèbre foire vous aimez
cet achat par contre les autres après
tout permis c'est le rock est non france
inter non non non non non ça ne jamais
croiser dans la rue jean pierre coffe
tf1 jean pierre coffe vous êtes danseur
à l'opéra wissam dit vaguement quelque
chose
bonsoir dites moi c'est que c'est pas
dieudonné veut bien bronzé vous dites
oui j'ai dû voir les nos amis les arabes
oui j'étais à marrakech oui j'ai fait un
petit break dans mon spectacle et surya
vraiment y avait du soleil neigé pas
ouais c'est à dire que ce spectacle donc
été prévu pour durer geste est prévue en
avril
en avril et ben apparemment puisque les
gens apparemment apprécié josiane les
gens viendront jake allen qui soit ans
qu'ils sont là comme ça c'était bien ce
qu'on va manger est comme ça ouais tous
les soirs jusqu'au 19 janvier va donner
on peut se passer
ces 100 francs pour les étudiants ah
ouais et pendant 160 franz en sachions
plus de thunes suis pas je bénis 190 me
suis mis en scène par muriel robin c'est
votre amie muriel robin oui oui c'est
monaco
j'ai commencé ensemble avec roger louret
qui maintenant fait les années tubes
avec gérard louvin sur tf1 roger louret
éclats la bande des années tubes que
nous aimons beaucoup ici je dois dire et
alors vous étiez dans un spectacle comme
ça ça fait les baladins de la jeune et
trucs mais j'essaie quand j'étais petit
j'avais 19 ans ouais et alors le
spectacle c'est lé folie amoureuse de
revenir c'était quoi le régnard va c'est
un auteur du xviie siècle
ç'a sûrement un copain de molière c'est
le même style et moi je faisais un petit
valet et muriel robin c'est la jeune
première
je faisais la jeune oui moi j'ai vu
robin au zénith
la semaine dernière elle est
exceptionnelle son nouveau spectacle
faut le dire parce que vraiment si vous
avez l'occasion d'avoir un spectacle
c'est le meilleur one woman show qu'elle
ait fait je pense que j'ai entendu les
autres mais même si la formidable hymne
à ce que moi aussi j'ai une oreillette
alors je suis en train de vie pose moins
de questions à temps ouais ouais non je
veux montrer aux téléspectateurs voilà
j'ai ça dans le rail c'est bien que les
gens de sa sonata la patrie donc oui
d'accord je lui demande combien il a
vendu deux cassettes dacquois la salle
est vendu combien de cas je pense qu'on
n'est pas loin des 300 milles pour sa
vie augmente et demi tout cas la rente
est bon et ça va ça va très bien sont
ils sont contents
alors vous avez sorti un livre si on me
demande de vous de vous demander alors
si on me demande moi de ne pas vous
répondre je suis moi aussi je veux bien
lui répond non plus entendu parler de
son bouquin hockey ouais ça ne me
dérangera franck est d'accord je lui dit
non mais si c'est comme ça je l'enlève
ainsi c'est pour me dire ce qu'il faut
dire pendant toute l'émission je vais
l'enlever tout de suite
bon bon aujourd'hui mais j'ai entendu
j'entends france inter qu on m'autorise
on m'autorise donc à vous demander c'est
pas lieu d'opposer un petit lisala je te
mets où tu veux
parce que moi je me demandais où il
fallait le mettre hors la fédé le livre
s'appelle plaisante évidemment ça
s'appelle plaisanterie swiss un recueil
de poésie sur la poésie
quand j'étais jeune pour séduire les
jeunes filles je suis arrivée des poèmes
mais écrit un truc à une belle phrase
d'ailleurs vous êtes ces petits c'était
je la cite parce que c'est vraiment de
les voir d'achat c'est un poids et
couettes l'eau ne sait pas nager
la preuve elle coule c'est ouais c'est
quand celle ci au baccalauréat crois moi
tu pas loin d'être aussi les autres tout
à fait c'est guy bergès ans que la
petite jeune fille et commence à tomber
amoureuse d'achat elle s'appelle tâche à
cette tâche à temps quand vous étiez
petit effectivement où tout le monde
vous casser la gueule et crottes
d'autres et vous poser pour résister
pour résister vous avez développé
l'humour
si c'est ça c'est une chose que tu ne
connais pas encore non non non mais
cavendish
on espère que vous progressez documenté
vraiment non alors donc vous avez
déclaré j'en ai marre qu'on m'invite à
la télé en me disant venez juste pour
faire le con mais ça fait souvent arrivé
way or là je suis à la bourre du tout là
vendu votre spectacle déjà il sait pas
fini votre lit machin pas le conduite ou
non mais souvent c'est vrai que la télé
ccc difficile le rang pour aime le dire
pour confirmer ce que je dis c'est que
quand on est artiste on se fait bouffer
par la télé on sert de faire valoir aux
animateurs on est là à côté de gens qui
font des rubriques qui présentera valoir
aux artistes alors donnons pour
accueillir valoir à l'autre non en fait
les vraies émissions bien je pense c'est
celle qui met en valeur les artistes ont
leur long les laisse parler de leurs de
ce qu'ils font et ses îles sont pas
juste là parce qu'ils sont connus parce
qu'ils font parce qu'ils disent trois
conneries et qui déstabilise et les gens
enfin dans mon cas en tout cas on m'a
souvent appelés pour dire à vient faire
le con machin il y a dix jeux à la télé
on est de l'achat on en est de la chair
à audience on sert qu'à faire l'audience
alors g demain matin si vous êtes de la
censure et si vous êtes vraiment de la
chair à audience oui ça nous apporte les
célébrités la de passer comme ça dans
des talk shows la télévision mais
finalement c'est une sorte de pacte avec
le diable
bah oui c'est ce que je viens de dire
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
enfin c'est délicat quand on fait trop
de télé qu'on a envie de faire du cinéma
on peut pas faire de cinéma quand on
nous voit trop à l'aller on fait plus
rêver les gens n'auraient pas parler
alors évidemment si vous deviez partir
sur une île déserte
kalfine de boer quel film que vous
emporteriez vous à la basse terre j'ai
fait que des chefs-d'oeuvre alors c'est
simple et c'est compliqué il accélère
mois pendant vos fils je racontais mes
blagues pour pouvoir y vivre c'est moche
comme un tissu retrouvés
je vais vider
c'est nickel a parlé moi j'en avais pas
parlé mission maman avait tourné
on m'avait demandé de ne pas en parler
c'est lui qui m'a parlé du cinéma des
films de 10 et moon jean-pierre de qui
des lycées est sympa écoutez je vous dis
je
je n'ai pas plus vu de film d'elie
semoun tube de qui que ce soit d'autre
je suis allé au cinéma de piste hier
notre bergerac oui quand même un bon
moment vu la création il se lie à part
ça j'aime énormément ce qui fait
s'affronter un type qui a beaucoup de
talent et puis il ya aussi depuis le
cloud c'était parce milow claude
franchement charity-business non plus
c'était pas mal ça j'ai pasqualetti
business et ainsi max mind c'était oui
c'est rigolo moi j'avais vu avec ophélie
winter
oui tout doit disparaître qu'un titre
dans ces territoires
as tu des souvenirs et on aimerait qu'on
vient de voir
mais quand il quand il est seul sur
scène il jamais ce genre de garçon
d'achat je pense que c'est un équivalent
artistes on croit que c'est un garçon
qui pour vous draguez vous faire rire
est ce que pour vous draguez près
puisque draghi il faut vous faire rire
ah c'est très important
allomo à l'humour en général je pense à
l'intelligence c'est l'intelligence
aussi puissant il a nous a montré jeu là
les deux je ne peux pas vous montrer mon
cerveau mais en tout cas j'en ai acheté
voilà on a compris ça et si l'ouverture
respecte revenons au spectacle parce
qu'on est là pour parler de votre
travail et pas juste pour vous regarder
faire le pont dites moi vous avez
déclaré
c'est dur d'écrire seul il vous manque
votre ami
avant non enfin au début il m'a manqué
forcément ça me déstabilisait 2000 et
bien non mais sérieusement je sais aussi
bien quand vous étiez avec lui oui oui
tout à fait non mais sérieusement mai
oui au départ il maintenant qu
évidemment c'est vrai que là cette
séparation pour moi a été un peu plus
dur que pour lui j'en suis sûr mais mais
une fois que muriel robin a décidé de
s'occuper de mon spectacle mettre en
scène le spectacle je me suis sentie
complètement en confiance et j'ai plus
pensé à lui est possible un jour voir
ensemble je sais pas franchement est ce
que vous avez dit sur lui ça
m'étonnerait que vous avez déclaré c'est
un ex vendeur de bagnols il était obsédé
par le pognon quoi c'est pas sympa mais
c'est vrai oui voilà c'est la vérité
alors non je lui fais pas de la peine
quand vous dites ça ça lui c'est pas de
la pole et non je crois pas il aime ça
il est c'est vrai que c'est un homme
d'affaires moi j'en suis pas du tout un
gars vous avez dit d'ailleurs oui vous
avez dit j'étais un peu lui c'était un
peu le juge du spectacle est moins noir
qui se fait avoir
oui c'est une blague mais c'est une
blague mais c'est la vérité c'est la
vérité ces fins anti série sun est
anticipée d'ici là il a un truc fort
bien que vous n'êtes pas raciste bien
évidemment mais vous jouez beaucoup avec
le racisme vous attendez un des seuls
comics en france qui joue avec le racing
présente un jour on vous demandait si
dieudonné s'en va vous dit si tu donnes
et s'en va je tape sur une poubelle pour
trouver un autre noir par exemple et
comme c'est vous personne ne dit rien ça
peut paraître méchant ou est-ce que la
vue comme ça c'est méchant non mais moi
dû donner je laime je les aime beaucoup
encore je trouve qu'il a beaucoup de
talent mais il est parti dans un délire
qui n'est pas le mien quoi la politique
les histoires d'argent etc
c'est pas mon truc ouais que voilà c'est
tout
quand vous dites par exemple tant mieux
avec le juif les nazis en avec les
huîtres les nazis ont pas fini le boulot
par exemple vous vous dites ça c'était
dans un sketch mais ça choque personne
c'est dieudonné qu'il disait dans un
sketch était un juif et un noir qui se
taper sur la gueule mais on est très on
a souvent pratiqué je la pratique encore
le l'autodérision je me souviens qu'à
l'époque on avait une affiche ou moi
j'étais en ss bien on le sait c'est
dieudonné un cucs clan puis on se
serrait la main comme ça avec un grand
sourire
donc c'est un petit peu de la
provocation quoi l'inspecteur
l'inspecteur oui votre lotion ce sketch
mais pourquoi pas cela dans ce sketch la
wii pour aller je vous dire en anglais
ses sketches en tout cas c'est un
non justin que y'a rien de ce gâchis en
garde à vue en fait ils parlent un
commissaire et il est interrogé sur ce
qu'il a fait et on s'aperçoit donc
arriver expliqué est-ce que vous avez
été arrêtés dans votre avec les mon
spectacle en fait c'est tout mes
cauchemars et la mort la police la
bêtise le racisme si vous êtes dans la
nuit les haut-rhinois bon face à la
suite on poste open